the boeing 737 max returned to the sky
with passengers for the first time since
it was grounded in 2019
following a pair of deadly crashes the
faa lifted its ban on the jet last month
and american airlines is now trying to
restore confidence in the plane
chris van cleef was among the members of
the media on board
yesterday's demonstration flight
just two weeks after the faa deemed a
number of design
changes made the boeing 737 max safe to
fly again
american airlines flight 9750 lifted off
from dallas
with about 100 on board we were among
the mix of media airline employees and
union leaders
this is a demo flight part of americans
efforts to get people
comfortable with being back on board the
737 max this is essentially
the first time the public has been
allowed to fly the plane since it was
grounded 20 months ago
american plans to start regular
scheduled commercial passenger service
by the end of the year how comfortable
are you flying the 737 max today
i'm very comfortable captain peter
gamble flew us to tulsa
he completed the new additional pilot
training for the max required by the faa
before the flight they needed to hear
from the line pilots needed to hear what
we demanded for training
and we now have it we have the computer
base but more importantly we have the
simulator training
which is really what we should have had
from the beginning we're already
starting to see some people that want to
actually
book and fly in the max david seymour is
american's chief operating officer
he says the max will be ready to resume
passenger service december 29th
in the middle of the next holiday travel
rush our pilots our mechanics or flight
attendants are all comfortable it's
ready to get in the air
airline analyst henry hartevelt bringing
it back on a route like new york miami
at new year's that's just odd it is more
financially related than customer
related
ahead of the 29th americans 24 max
planes are undergoing thousands of
man-hours of work at this tulsa
maintenance facility
we watched as mechanics installed the
faa mandated software update
to fix the design flaws that led to two
deadly crashes
and the plane's grounding is the knack
safe and ready to fly
absolutely chris we would not let this
airplane leave tulsa if it wasn't safe
and ready to fly
at an event like this you would
typically expect to hear from the
airline's
ceo doug parker is essentially the face
of american airlines but he didn't
attend
he opted to fly the max the day before
the event there was no
one from the public no media no one
asked him any questions about the
airplane
what american is being clear about is
the booking process the airline says it
will be
very very clearly stated that somebody
is flying a max if they change their
mind and want to be on a different
aircraft
they will let them change with no fee
anthony
thank you chris some folks are still
going to need a lot of convincing i
think to get on board